Arthur does it help to have someone to
talk to
[Music]
my mother always tells me to smile and
put on a happy face
she told me I had a purpose to bring
laughter and joy to the world
is it just me or is it getting crazier
out there
though your harvies akin smile even
though it's breaking when there are
cloud in the sky
you'll get by but if you see sorrows and
maybe tomorrow
what's so funny just freak
[Music]
Gotham's lost its way
what kind of coward would do something
that cold-blooded someone who hides
behind a mask
[Music]
[Applause]
I used to think that my life was a
tragedy
[Music]
it's a comedy
you just
[Music]
hi everyone is Charlie put on a happy
face because we had a breakdown this new
Joker trailer so it actually looks
pretty fantastic we didn't really know
what to expect of it when we saw the
footage a little while ago even when
they announced it it sounded a little
confusing but now seeing all the
references and the influences it
actually totally makes sense so you
probably recognize a lot of familiar
things during this especially Robert
DeNiro the film is largely inspired by
the 1928 film the man who laughs which
that film also inspired a lot of the
look and feel of the Joker character in
the comics when Bill Finger Bob Kane and
Jerry Robinson first created the
character there's also a lot of
influence from Charlie Chaplin's modern
times and Martin Scorsese's king of
comedy you even see Robert De Niro in a
very on-the-nose role during the film so
we'll break all these Easter eggs down
there's a new round of the IMAX take a
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Joker moment from the comics or the
movies on the video why so serious
put on a happy face every reference to
every version of the Joker that you've
ever seen before wait till they get a
load of me even though Jack Nicholson's
version of the Joker is a bit of a
departure from the comics himself this
obviously is a very different spin on a
Joker origin story we've never gotten
that before part of the reason why the
Joker does not have an origin story is
because he's such a force of chaos he
actually works better the less you know
about him he's not really a character
that's supposed to make sense you're not
meant to understand his perspective or
anything like that because you're always
viewing him from Batman's perspective
that's part of his curse he never truly
knows his identity it was an arc after
Darkseid war where he briefly gain
control of the Mobius chair and got the
powers of a new god gained all knowledge
and learned the identity of three
different jokers that was meant to
reconcile three different Joker origin
stories from different eras in the
comics the classic the modern comics and
in the more recent stuff during the new
52 they also paid a reference to all
those different origin stories when
Heath Ledger would tell a different
version of his origin story to his
victims during the Dark Knight as his
Joker character you want to know how I
got these scars and he would always tell
a different story so this movie is not
intended to connect to any of the modern
Batman films not the Dark Knight trilogy
not Ben Affleck's version of Batman and
not Matt Reeves version of Batman who
will probably find out about pretty soon
because they're supposed to start
filming that Batman prequel
movie later this year think of this like
DC black label in the comics just like a
really hardcore really cool story that
sort of exists in its own level of
continuity the trailer doesn't really
give you a sense for it but I believe
it's also supposed to be r-rated the
trailer opens up on a very 1970s era
looking Gotham just like the clothes
people are wearing all the televisions
technology the cars just seems like it's
taking place around the same time that
Martin Scorsese did his movie King of
Comedy
so the Joker's real name is Arthur let's
he starts by talking to his therapist
here I'm assuming that this might be in
Arkham Hospital where he's going to
visit her where he gets his medicine
from fun fact this person who seems like
he's buzzing him into the hospital here
is Brian Tyree Henry who played Miles
Morales as dad in spider-man into the
spider verse you recognize his voice
once you hear him speak in the movie you
can see that he's suffering from mental
illness he's writing about it in his
journal there but he's also caring for
his mother who also seems like she's
suffering from mental illness as well so
Todd Phillips said that when he was
trying to explain the movie to the
marketing department at Warner Brothers
like okay we need a pitch to sell this
movie he said that all I could tell them
is that it's a tragedy so you sort of
see the world around him in Gotham
erupting into chaos and him trying to
reconcile that in his brain until he
comes to the very joker like conclusion
that he should just laugh at everything
it's all meaningless and it's sort of
like the chaotic ideology that he has in
the more modern incarnations of the
character once he's taken the mantle so
when Michael Caine's Alford character
says some men just want to watch the
world burn this movie shows you how he
got there and this version of Gotham is
definitely crap town like you look at
the strip where he works here as the
clown spinning that sign this reminds me
a lot of 1970s New York City Times
Square before it was Disney fied with
all the stuff that you see in modern-day
Times Square if you've ever seen
pictures or if you are alive in New York
City in the 1970s that was one of the
worst decades ever to live in New York
City it really did resemble the dark
gritty version of Gotham City until they
started cleaning things up but you see
Arthur talking to his therapist and he
tells the story my mother tells me to
put on a happy face you see him bathing
his mother trying to get up in the
morning getting very upset about how
people demonize mental illness writing
about it in his journal here so he does
seem very sympathetic early in the
trailer because those kids steal a sign
then he chases after them they smash it
in his face you see him at the donut
shop was AZ Beach
she's playing Sophie Dumont who I
believe is meant to be his friend or his
girlfriend during the movie he goes to
Arkham hospital to get his medicine like
I said this is Bryan Tyree Henry from
spider-man into the spider verse you see
him at the comedy club pogos Pogo is
actually a political satire comic book
strip that goes back to 1913 so there's
a lot of references baked into here to
the world of comedy and a lot of special
movie references that I'll explain as we
go along joaquin phoenix gives off that
crazy forced laugh like he hasn't become
the joker yet but it seems like in this
moment he's trying to force himself to
laugh like he's kind of trying to make
sense of things before they completely
descend into chaos but I think that Marc
Maron who's playing a character in the
film is the announcer at this comedy
club even though we don't see him in any
of this footage you see him at his job
in the morning putting his clown makeup
on forcing himself to lap pulling his
lips into a very Joker like smile
looking like he's slowly starting to
break down he seems like he's hit rock
bottom when he's on the subway laughing
like this is him before he's become the
Joker still he's sort of laughing and
crying at the same time like laughing
because he's so upset
then the drunk douchebags punched him
out he exits in the alleyway it starts
running through it's hard to tell when
some of these scenes are happening
sequentially during the film but
probably not one right after the other
him here in this bathroom in his clown
makeup seems like when he's sort of
reached his then it's like he really is
starting to go crazy but you hear them
play that song smile during the trailer
wall this is happening put on a happy
face that's actually a song written by
Charlie Chaplin for his movie modern
times like you see him at the theater
here where modern times is playing the
song was never actually sung during that
movie it was re-recorded by several
different people so you probably heard
at least some version of the song but
modern times itself was Charlie
Chaplin's commentary on the terrible
living conditions of the poor during the
Great Depression obviously a lot of this
joker movie is commentary on how society
treats mental illness in the poor he
start to hear the voiceover from Thomas
Wayne played by Brent Cullen on that
news broadcast railing against a
criminal wearing a mask he's obviously
talking about the Joker during this
wearing a clown mask on top of his Joker
makeup on this
way here it's probably when he
perpetrates one of his first crimes
after he's officially taken the mantle
the IMDB does not list who this cop
actor is playing he could be detective
Gordon he could be Bullock it just
usually the reason why they don't tell
you who notable characters are playing
or because they're really big comic-book
people then you get the scene at Wayne
Manor of the Joker interacting with a
young Bruce Wayne through the bars so
even though the Joker is obviously the
villain of the Batman comics he's the
protagonist of The Joker movie the big
twist is is that the antagonist of the
Joker movie I believe is meant to be
thomas wayne even though we know thomas
wayne is this really benevolent father
it's just in this portrayal from the
Joker's perspective he is the enemy
clearly the Joker's a little obsessed
with Thomas Wayne that's why he seeks
him out at his mansion but finds his
young son Bruce Wayne on the grounds
providing you with a nice common point
of origin for those two characters so it
also gives you an idea for the
differences in their ages because the
Joker in the comics is meant to be quite
a bit older than Bruce Wayne I don't
know if we're gonna see the origin story
in Crime Alley if we're gonna watch
Thomas Wayne and Martha Wayne die during
this in the comics it was Joe Chill that
wound up killing the Wayne's but in the
Michael Keaton version of the Batman
origin story it was Jack Nicholson's
Joker before he became the Joker that
killed his parents I don't know what
kind of a moment they're gonna try and
end this movie on obviously they want to
go out with a bang so it's probably
gonna be some really notable Batman
comic book reference but then you see
Arthur's seeming like he's trying to
perform at that comedy club that he went
to earlier you see the pace of the
trailer start to pick up as if he's
slowly going crazy you see him in a
bunch of different points in time like
he bangs his head on the glass here then
later you see him getting ready to go on
this big news broadcast in full Joker
makeup this is him in the green room for
that TV show getting ready to go on you
see Robert De Niro who seems like he's
the host of this television show in what
seems like the biggest on-the-nose
reference to Martin Scorsese's King of
Comedy if you've never seen that movie
is actually pretty interesting but it's
a very dark satire on attention-seeking
culture and the way that society treated
Fame at that time obviously it hasn't
gotten any better but Robert De Niro
plays a psychopath who wants to become a
comedian and idealizes Jerry Lewis's
character winds up kidnapping him trying
to get famous through his crime he's
later arrested
goes to jail it works exactly like he
wanted it to when he gets out of prison
he writes a book he gets famous for his
crimes and then goes on a television
show that looks just like this but then
you see a couple different shots of him
in full Joker makeup getting hit by a
cab on the street you see him putting on
his full Joker makeup dyeing his hair
green walking out of the apartment like
a badass just dancing down the steps
that you earlier saw him walking up in
the trailer so it seems like a very
clever take on a version of his origin
story but I would treat it like that
just another version of his origin story
so like you have the three different
Joker's in the comics you have the
slightly different Jack Nicholson
version of the origin story you have
Heath Ledger's Joker you now have
walking Phoenix's version of the Joker
and I think he's great at playing these
creepy types of characters so he is some
8 plus casting but let me know in the
comments if you spotted any other Batman
comic book references or references to
other films in the movie I'm sure
there's a billion other comic book
references in the film itself so it's
coming out this October of course I'll
do videos for it but if you have any
special video requests leave them in the
comments below there was an alternate
Avengers and game trailer that posted
last night after the other trailer so
I'll probably do a new video for that
new footage but there's a whole bunch of
Game of Thrones and other things that'll
be happening this week just leave all
your requests in the comments below and
I'll name a giveaway winner when I post
new DC so if you haven't seen it you can
click here for my non-spoilery Shazam
review be sure to go see that movie and
you can click here to rewatch that brand
new Avengers and game trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome and put on a happy face
[Music]